Let's pray together today over day 26, "Holiness is the
sprinkling that cleanses from idols."
Today, I'm sitting in
my home studio in a walk-in closet,
and I'm seeking the Lord together with you today as
there's noise from my family in the background, and my wife
playing the piano, and kids running around hollering at each other.
And I just want to remind you that there is nothing about ordinary
life that is incompatible with seeking holiness.
If you want to know God, he's ready to reveal himself
to you.
Today's written prayer is from John Newton.
"Dear Lord, the idol self dethrone,
and from our hearts remove,
and let no zeal by us be shown, but that
which springs from love."
Father, we pray today over Ezekiel 36,
and we thank you for the provision that you've made to truly make
us clean.
Not just an initial cleansing of our conscience of
guilt,
because the Israelites, many of them, did that many
times.
But also to cleanse us from the stiff-necked,
stubborn-hearted impurity of our hearts
and from all idols.
Lord, we reach out our hands to you because we have nowhere
else to go to receive this. There is no other
bloodshed. No bull or goat can cleanse the
idols of the heart.
No formal sprinkling by any other being on this
earth could ever make the spiritual transformation that we
need. But you promised that you would give
us a new heart and put a new spirit within us,
and remove our hard and stony heart and give us a heart of
flesh.
We believe, Lord, that you're able to bring us to a place of obedience to you, and
so we ask for that with humble hearts and expectant hearts
and say, Lord, cleanse our heart from every idol and make
it clean.
Let's continue praying as we seek the Lord together.